America I hope you're ready for more out
of control radical policies Democrats
barely squeaked out a win in Nevada to
keep control of the Senate and now they
think it means that they have a mandate
to shove their outrageous Progressive
policies down our throats
this Victory belongs to Joe Biden it
belongs to Joe Biden and the Democrats
who got out there and fought for working
people the things we did were important
and popular Joe Biden's approached an
offender were exactly the things that we
needed in this country and that's what
people voted for I predicted the young
people were going to vote for us why we
focused on climate which they really
care about there's no
there's no the house maybe the liberal
cheerleaders need to listen to the guy
they're all praising
I think we're going to get very close in
the house but I don't I think it's going
to be very close but I think we're going
to make
even the mainstream media thinks it
would have been worse for Democrats if
Biden had emerged from the basement on
the campaign Trail no doubt it's a it's
such a good night for Biden however it
does seem when you look at the exit
polls that Democrats prevailed in spite
of him not because of him necessarily I
mean cnnxupulture that 49 of Voters who
said they somewhat disapprove of Biden
voted for Democrats while 45 back
Republicans so I mean you see Biden he's
sat off on the campaign Trail and a lot
of these key races he wasn't making
these big campaign pushes he wasn't
front and center and that seemed to help
Democrats Jessica Tarlov do Democrats
have a mandate
yeah what is it
it's to continue governing it to at
least have control of the Senate and the
house like Biden is right I think will
be down two or three seats but it's a
strange idea that after pulling off
something of historic proportions when
you look back through history this was
an incredibly good night for Democrats
that were expected to then turn around
the next day and be like oh we're so
terrible we're so terrible the American
people didn't say oh you're so terrible
they said actually Republicans
especially ones who denied the outcome
of the election or were aligned aligned
with Donald Trump that you're so
terrible I looked back at the real clear
politics projections the GOP was
supposed to be sitting on 54 seats right
now
49 right and we have a very good chance
of taking Georgia as well people got
this wildly wrong and I think it's very
unfair for anyone to think that people
who ended up Define historical
expectations should then turn around and
kind of bow down to a party that managed
to bungle something like this and I
understand Kevin McCarthy is going to be
challenged for the leadership I don't
know if anyone else can get over the 50
there but there is no way that Mitch
McConnell and Kevin McCarthy manage this
well I mean there were people talking
about Patty Murray losing her seat is
completely ridiculous
do I owe you money you do
how much do I owe you Jessica you owe me
a hundred dollars and you owe Geraldo a
thousand dollars okay here you go I'm
not sure if I'm still gonna pay Heraldo
but you have to there's 100 that's like
big it's very fancy it's real all right
okay let's get over okay stop stop all
right enough what do you think the
Democrats are saying oh this is so
Progressive we're the most Progressive
the country didn't vote for a more
Progressive Democrat Party look the
Democrats are taking this as a mandate
and the way Jessica sees it and the way
the Democrats see it is it is a mandate
it will this will be the most
Progressive next two years that that
we've ever seen and that's great for
2024. but what's crazy about all of this
is you have one of the most unpopular
Presidents in history you've got
incredible problems with inflation with
the economy economy with Afghanistan
everything about what we've been through
for the last two years has been a
nightmare and and I'll tell you what won
this election for the Democrats sure the
young people came out and vote and they
got paid I mean they got the student
loans paid back it was a buyout I mean
that's what happened with them but the
other thing is abortion it was all about
abortion Joe Biden didn't do abortion
abortion just kind of fell out of the
Supreme Court for whatever reason in May
or June of this year and that was it
that's all the Democrats needed now
they're going to beat their chest
they're going to say well it's because
we're so great Joe Biden what a leader
America hates them okay and that's all I
have to say okay Greg do you remember in
2018 those men I don't remember anything
possible let me jog your memory Donald
Trump's Republican party actually added
a bunch of seats in the U.S Senate and
lost about 40 in the house they actually
did better in those midterms and bidened
it in these yeah and you could argue I
mean you could argue and I think it's a
clear argument that Republicans are
better off now that they have the house
so isn't that a mandate I mean I don't
know but I think what what uh what um
the judge is saying is correct the
actual historic
kind of the historic moment wasn't this
election it was Roe v Wade being
overturned and it's kind of it it's kind
of interesting that the Dems are still
going to lose the house and it should
have been worse it should have been
worse but it wasn't but that is because
the Supreme Court expended the political
Capital that was built for decades to
overturn Roe v Wade that was built that
was baked into the cake right so they
the hill that the right chose to die on
was Roe v Wade and they uh and and this
might have been the right time to do it
because they still got the house we
don't know but I think that right this
is an achievement I mean what's the
point what's the point of building
political power if you don't spend it
yeah right so that's what made this so
close is that you know if you were a
constitutionalist and a pro-lifer you
should be very happy stepping back and
going after this election going well it
didn't go as good as I wanted but
there's Roe v Wade being overturned and
we got the house in spite of that and I
was willing to die on that Hill because
that Hill is made of millions of unborn
children so I should be willing to fight
for that long-term short-term decades so
if you're just looking too close at the
trees you're not seeing the forest there
isn't Jessica's right this came down
this was you said it last week this is
about abortion
everybody takes it seriously including
the people that took four four decades
to get to this point and I think and
there may be consequences for the
Republican Party verb ongoing but the
thing is there's going to be part of the
of the Republicans that say so what this
is when you have to expend that Capital
some what's the point what's the point
of being a political party that was a
very good analysis why thank you a very
excellent Greg I hadn't thought about
that that way so Joe Biden doesn't go
campaign at all for anybody what does
that tell you about his political
Capital think that it means that I
actually well
I think that they just had a good
strategy they had a good strategy in
2020 they used covet as an excuse to not
campaign he didn't really it didn't
really bother him that he was
campaigning in Delaware and Maryland and
New York
um and I think that pro-life people vote
too and they're they're going to be an
increasing number of these state
referendums that are going to happen but
if you think about the look at the
governor of Ohio there's some strict
abortion restrictions in Ohio he won
so did Rick's um sorry not Rick Scott
Ron DeSantis well Rhonda Santos in
Florida wins Big Time as a governor
there there's a Statewide issue there
Georgia Brian Kemp so the abortion issue
was more complicated for republicans in
the New England states in particular and
also in Michigan that's where and where
Wisconsin and there was a state
referendum in at least Ron Johnson won
though but in Michigan for example you
know they had the University of Michigan
had students lined up all around the
block and an initiative like that or a
referendum like that can drive people to
the polls and Jim Messina uh whose
Democratic guy for Obama he was on our
show Newsroom and he said if I have
anything to do with it I'm going to make
sure that those state referendums are on
all the other states in 2024 why would
they do that so when it comes to the
Senate I think there's 33 seats up in 24
of the seats the Democrats are going to
be on the defense so they're going to
need an issue so we'll have to consider
all of that going forward but I would
also say this it's well the Republicans
might be disappointed they did win some
good things they kept some governor's
mansions that were important to them
they also increased with Latinos Asian
Americans and black Americans and you're
not going to win all of those groups all
at once but they found a foothold and
they continued to gain to gain there so
I think that they'll do that also I
would say there's not going to be a
mandate for either side I don't think I
think there will be gridlock and
gridlock is okay I love gridlock I love
it except for on when you go home yeah
exactly all right the irony hi winner
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now